[Music]  if you're looking for a way to play  injustice to before launch then you'll  be happy to hear that an online beta  test has been confirmed for the super  hero fighting game I'm Matt and this  gamespot news update is team Batman  after a tease from the ever so cryptic  Ed Boon a beta registration page went  live you can sign up for the online test  now which will run on both ps4 and xbox  one but it's not clear when it starts or  how long it will last we'll report back  when more information is revealed  injustice to release for ps4 and xbox  one on May sixteenth a recent story  trailer revealed characters Brainiac  Robin and dark side the latter of which  is available to players who pre-order  the game other characters confirmed  include Batman Superman Supergirl Wonder  Woman and Harley Quinn those are just a  few of them and we'll keep you updated  as even more are revealed so for that  and much more stay tuned to gamespot